uh so I guess so today we're going to
um on the last lecture on reinforcement
learning and I'll probably spend like
five minutes to briefly wrap up the
whole course but mostly we're gonna talk
about reinforcement learning so
um so this is supposed to be a more kind
of like introduction into introductory
lecture on some of the a little more
advanced topics in reinforcement
learning so I wouldn't talk about a lot
about details but mostly I'm going to
Define some terms and so that it's
easier for you to kind of like either
take another course on reinforcement
learning or read some of the literatures
yourself
so I guess last time we have introduced
the basic concept concept of mdp a
Markov decision process that's the main
language that people use to think about
reinforcement questions I'm going to
start by just reviewing some of the the
key idea to recall that you have mdp
Markov decision process this is a kind
of like
um it's described by a few important
Concepts so one thing is the state space
you have to specify the state space to
specify the mdp you have to specify the
action space
and the mdp has this transition
probability which is called PSA for
every s and every a
H ice is is in the
um ice is the state is the action for
every I said a you have this so-called
transition uh probability Matrix or
transition probabilities which is to
describe what is the probability that if
you start with a state s and take action
a what is the probability to arrive at a
new state
so
um and there is the so-called discount
Factor gamma and a reward function r
so after specifying these five
quantities you get mdp
and we also talked about the concept of
a policy
so policy is something you are trying to
learn from interacting with the system
the environment
um you're trying to learn the so-called
policy which is a function that maps
from the state and action so this policy
tells you what you do what which action
do you take when you see your state s
um so Pi of ice is the action you take
when you are either State s
um and we also introduced these two
concept uh two type of value function so
the first type of value function is the
value function of the state s so this is
the value of the state s and then the
policy Pi so this is the expected reward
uh expected future payoff
um of
uh executing
the policy pi from
say the S right so you keep update you
keep
um you keep taking action from the
policy Pi you start with State s and
then you cut you you compute what is the
total future payoff in expectation and
that's V pile of x
so and we also
discuss this so-called V Star of us
this is oblivious to the policy Pi this
is asking you know what's the maximum
possible reward you can get
from starting from State s right so you
maximize over all possible policies and
you look at you maximize the V pile
phase
um and the maximizer of this
process the arc Max of this is kind of
the optional policy you care about you
want to find out what is the optimal
policy
all right so I think we probably didn't
have time to Define this you know
um uh formula last time so the optimal
policy Pi star is the so-called uh uh
the arc Max
hi
and this this is actually
um
there's a unique Pi star that maximized
the vpa is for every X
just because the policy itself is
already a function of us right so you're
finding a policy that Maps the function
as to the action you already can take
different actions for different status
so
um
and this is one way to this Define this
and another way to define this is the
following so this is another way to
define optional policies you say that
this is the greedy policy
with respect to
V Star so so this is alternative
definition of the optimal policy which
is defined to be Pi star of iris is
defined to be the
the best action you take such that you
maximize your future payoff what's your
future payoff the future payoff is
equals to R of s
plus the payoff you get from the future
steps which is gamma times
um
this PSA
as Prime this is sum over S Prime this
is the probability that you see your X
Prime after you take action a which is
the variable here
and then you times V Star
X Prime
right so this part
is the expected reward you take you you
the best reward you can get after you
take policy you after you take action 8
right you take action a you have some
chance to wrap at S Prime and you
multiply the best payoff you can get
after your after starting from X Prime
and and this so that's why this is the
expected the best possible expect payoff
after you take action and this is the
payoff you get at State s so the total
thing is the best payoff including the
current payout the current return the
best future payoff if you take action
and you maximize over a and that's the
the best policy the best that's that's
the definition of the optimal policy
right so because this is already of the
optimal Choice you're already thinking
about the optional choice for all the
future steps and then you take the
action a that is the optimal
um for this step
taking into account the future steps and
that's the optimal policy for the status
any questions
I mean sometimes this is the way to find
out the optimal policy because if you
find out what's the the V Star then you
can find out the opt-in policy because
you just take the greedy policy with
respect to P star
and we also introduced this important
concept of bellman equation which is the
main tool that we use to find out to
compute V pi and V Star so for V Pi if
you're given Pi then about my equation
for v Pi uh
Development question for V Pi is equals
is this so V path is equal to RS
plus gamma
times this
right so so so most of the Belmont
equations you can pretty much verify
intuitive for yourself right so because
what is the the reward the payoff when
you when you write State s accessing
policy Pi you first look at what's the
current reward for this step and then UK
what's the future reward the future
reward involved can be computed by
considering all different possible
outcomes of executing pile files right
so if you apply a pile of us then you
can you have some problems around S
Prime and that's you multiply that
probability with the the the the payoff
you get after arriving at State as per
okay and and this is uh and one of the
important thing here was that this is
actually linear
uh in the variable we pass
so linear in
uh in this
um in a variable V Pi one up to V pi
uh I I think I used M as the number of
total States so so this is a linear
equation of these variables so you can
solve the linear equation by any linear
system solver
and we also introduced this uh
um
equation for v star which is of a
familiar form but the difference is that
now you don't have the pi you are you
have to maximize uh the action so you
have RS
plus a Max you take the Max Plus the
best possible action
that maximize the future
reward
right so so now this is not a linear
equal system equations in terms of V
Star but you can use the so-called on
the the algorithm we introduced last
time was this iterative algorithm that
you do the Bell map update iteratively
uh you can do this iterative algorithm
to find out restart
and the question so far this is
basically a review of the last lecture
so
um
okay so so far we have deal with you
know in the last lecture we have to deal
with no Dynamics right so in all of this
right so we have described the algorithm
is so and so forth everything was you
know was kind of like under the
assumption that the algorithm so
basically the algorithm to solve the V
Pi or the algorithm cell V Star the
iterative algorithm I guess I'm not sure
whether you still remember the algorithm
the algorithm here was just something
very simple so you take a loop
and you just say I'm going to update V I
have a working
memory for v i update V
uh like a
vs updated to be something like RS plus
Max
but you just compute the right hand side
and then with the the V plugging in here
and then you update the the left hand
side with itself so this is called value
iteration
algorithmic cloud value iteration
so both the value iteration algorithm
and the algorithm that solves the linear
system equation in this case both of
these two algorithms are assuming you
have a known Dynamics
so the PSA is known
the all the family of PSA is known
um
um like in both of these two algorithms
because you have to compute PSA
right so so in in the arrow language you
are saying that this means that you have
the known transition Dynamics or the
known
um like uh environment that's how people
refer to this kind of settings so but in
reality what happens is that this PSA is
not known anymore so for example
thinking you know sometimes you do know
it right for example suppose you
consider this is a game like playing
goal right you are playing the goal or
chess so you do know the rules of the
game right you know what happens if you
play an action a what will happen next
right so you're gonna move this the each
of the the piece you know in some way
right so you know the root the rules
then then in those cases PSA is not but
in many other cases the transition
Dynamics is not known right so for
example when you control the robot right
so in some cases you probably know a
little bit about you if you control this
the robot would move forward but
sometimes if you're doing a low level
control you are changing the joint of
the robotic arm or the the hand your
body hand
um you don't exactly know how the the
all the all everything moves exactly you
probably have some rough sense but you
never you are never able to model them
exactly actually this is a challenge so
so this is actually the reason why kind
of like now people are using more and
more learning techniques so I think in
the in the early days I think for
example there was a company called
Boston Dynamics so what they do is they
basically just use rule-based so
basically they build this PSA they try
to figure out from physics what's
exactly this dynamical systems should it
look like and then they they build their
policies based on on that Dynamic
ecosystem so but um but these days I
think people are kind of like at least
trying to
apply more learning techniques because
there is no way you can figure out
exactly what PSA is on just just from
the physical rules you have to use some
kind of like learning based technique
sometimes also it involves interaction
with environments for example suppose I
have a robot that is moving on this
carpet then the speed will be different
from the robot moving on the on the
hardwood floor right so so so the so the
the other environment is also part so
like the floor the other things also
part of the environment so then you can
never model everything perfectly where
you would never know the texture of the
the floor exactly so so that's why we
have to learn the Dynamics to some
extent
so so I think that's the um that's what
that's the that's the in some sense
that's the real uh problem in
reinforcement learning where the
Dynamics is unknown so when you don't
have the Dynamics right so uh what what
can you do
so
um you have to know something right you
have to somehow have some information
about Dynamics so the typical assumption
which is is that
um so the the the PSA this is I know
but you have the but
given
a state s
and action a
uh we can sample
as Prime from this transition Dynamics
basically you can just try try the robot
in the real world we can just say I'm
going to try my action a in a real world
and see what's the next S Prime is right
the X Prime will involve a little
stochasticity you'll do some Randomness
but you're going to observe one random
sample from this transition Dynamics
um so so so so so so so that's why when
people call sample complex it means that
how many times you have to try this
where for how many state interaction you
have to try to see ice Prime
um by just try it in a real world
um so so that's how people generally
learn so learn by interacting with the
environment by trying all these actions
and and and you somehow learn the
Dynamics in some way
so that's the basic assumption and then
there are two type of algorithms in
reinforcement learning that are
um
the most popular I think most of the
algorithm can be either
categorized into one of this group so so
one one type of algorithm is called
Model based RL
so here the model means the dynamical
the model means the dynamic mode or the
transition Dynamics so as the name
someone suggests you know basically
model based arrow means that you
explicitly
uh learn
the transition Dynamics
how do you learn it that you know there
are multiple variants you know it
depends on the situations depends on
your how complex your Dynamic is but you
know the transition dynamics of the
transition probabilities
on probabilities I guess they mean
exactly the same thing for for you know
they already they probably just always
mean exactly the same thing
um but sometimes people have different
terms so so basically learn this PSA
or especially you build a model to
describe this PSA
um or like and you learn this model uh
from the the samples
the samples are the data you learn from
and and then you build some approximate
PSA from the samples and that's
um that's the typical kind of like types
of
um
um type of like a
the table types of kind of like uh model
based R algorithm
so from samples
Okay so
and there's another type of type of
algorithm which is called model 3rl
you know I don't think there is a really
a a precise definition of any of this
but in some sense the model 3 are I
would just say is the negation of this
right so you don't explicitly learn a
transition probability
so so just the the
doesn't
learn the transition
so it sounds a little bit kind of like
um
um you know if you don't have any
contacts you know this sounds might be a
little bit tricky because how come you
don't learn the Dynamics but still learn
the policy so it's possible for example
sometimes you can just directly optimize
um optimize this without learning the
Dynamics right so you can probably
um just uh
um you use some kind of like a stock so
so they are there you know there are
ways to to to note
um learn expressive dynamics of course
you know eventually any algorithm needs
to somehow have some understanding about
Dynamics internally in some sense but
you don't have to expressly build one
um right so for example one possible
option is just that you optimize this
function V pass over over the policy Pi
suppose you can somehow take really
descent over policy pi then you can
um you can avoid
dealing with the Dynamics where you
don't use the about my equation you just
somehow it'd be you just somehow compute
the derivative of this respect five
so some of the passwords you know are
like some some of the algorithms Q
learning is one type of algorithm and
another type of algorithm is called
policy gradients
so I don't think we have time to discuss
any of this model 3 algorithm I just
want to write them down here just the
buzzword so that you know if if you
happen to kind of like came across them
you know they are model 3 algorithm you
know in some of the quarters we do cover
this some of the course have well two
more lectures like depending on how many
holidays they are so
um
okay so and another kind of like a
um some of the kind of the definition of
terms people use here is that so
um there is something called
when you say tabular case or tablet RL
this means that you have decreased this
space discrete
uh
action
and state space
so on the other words the size
of the state space is finance
and and the size of the action space is
also finite and this and actually
impresses you are in some sense
whether it's final or not probably it's
not the most important thing the real
important thing is that the state and
action space are not too big they are
not like a billion or something they are
something that um that is reasonable
like in the last lecture we are we are
basically assuming this right we'll
assume that the state space is like has
an anxious right and and we didn't talk
that much about action space but we
implicitly say that we actually all the
algorithms required at the action space
to be somewhat confined and and you can
see like this uh for example
this linear system solver algorithm if
you want to solve the linear system
equations what are the variables the
variables are the V Pi one up to V Pi n
where m is the number of states so if m
is infinite then you cannot solve this
linear system equations where you have
infinite variables even if m is not
infinite even if m is something like
super big say like exponentially back or
something like a billion then you cannot
really afford time to solve this system
equations so so in some sense the most
important thing is that you really don't
want to have like if you are a type
blockage you are implicitly assuming
that the state space is not huge
um
but you know as you can see you know
sometimes the state space is just have
to be infinite or very big because you
have the state space is continuous right
so
um so so that's another case where you
have continuous
continuous database
sometimes you have continuous action
space as well so so for example the
state space is something like Rd
so you have a d dimensional Vector to
describe the state and your action
typically the action space is smaller
than a state space well maybe the action
space is something like RK where K is
smaller than D sometimes D can be like
100 or maybe sometimes even more than
100 action space typically if it's
continuous then K problem would be 5 10
or something like that
um and sometimes you have the
combination right so you have continuous
State space but find an action space
that's also possible
um for example if you for example one
table case where you have continuous
State space but a final action space is
a target game right you play this entire
game and you'll stay space is this pixel
space where you see the what like the
the the the the pixels right so that
that is showing to you and the actions
but actually are actually fine and you
just have a few buttons and maybe like
some kind of like handle you can you can
you can choose to play
um so the action space is somewhat final
um
all right so so these are just some kind
of like terms just in case they are
useful uh and when you read some of the
the other books or literatures
um okay so then in the next
um 20 minutes I'm going to discuss you
know how do you do the model maybe in
the next 30 minutes how do you do the
model based RL follow tabular case right
so so basically you can see that their
model based model 3 and tabular
continuous way is kind of like you have
two like four combinations and we're
going to do the model based Plus tabular
so
and this is actually not very hard so so
what you really want to do here is that
um
basically
model based
tabular
you want to learn expressive an
exclusive model
um on that kind of like a somewhat
simulator two model PSA so what you have
is that you have
um a collection so so
suppose
we have
a collection of trajectories
and forgot whether I Define trajectory
spectrojectors I just mean a sequence of
like State actions
um so suppose you say you you have some
state
as zero
uh maybe let's say
we start from the state as zero
and you take some action
maybe a0 and you arrive at S1 and you
take some action A2 A1 and you arrive at
S2 so and so forth
right so this is the one introduction
right a sequence of State actions right
so and so so far I'm not uh I didn't
really tell you how I got this reaction
but I'm I'm gonna talk about how do you
learn the the transition probability
from some game introductions right so
suppose I give one should actually and
so often you need more than one
production so then you say after I take
a bunch of steps maybe I take two steps
I reset so I reset and then I get
another traction that's called maybe
let's call this should actually ice zero
one a01
after super scriptures to indicate that
this is the first Factory and then I
restart I get a new initial State and I
call this as zero two
and then apply a0 to
S1 to
a12
so forth
so I got a and maybe I can get more
right I can get a bunch of three actors
here the subscript is indexing the time
and the superscript is indexing which
structure you are in
how do you ask me ask the transition
Dynamics recall that all of these State
and actions are discrete variables
because I'm in a typical case so so
basically I just have to estimate PSA
as Prime right what's the chance to
start with us and and take action a to
an arrive at Express
so this is kind of like a in some sense
the problem is the the same as the uh
some of this like I think we discussed
this generative learning algorithm where
we have this event model right where
everything is kind of content based so
um so basically you can you can compute
the Max mo likelihood of the of this
transition you view this as a parameter
right so this is something you want to
learn right this is a parameter and and
then you try to find out the maximum
likelihood
estimate for this parameter and it turns
out that it's just a as usual it's the
most kind of Natural Choice basically
you just count on the the frequency to
see this right you look you say
in the denominator you say I look at how
many times
uh like a
uh we let's say we took
action
hey I'd stay nice
so you basically look at all the cases
will take action a and state s and then
in the numerator you count how many
times
we took
action a at okay I guess maybe I'm a
little too worthy here so so basically
a number of times if you take action a
and say I State us and you arrive at I
Supply
so so the denominator is the total
number of times you take the action I
State us and the numerator is how many
among all of this
occurrences of ice and a how many times
you indeed arrive as S5
and
um and then that's that's your
transition probability that's that's
your estimated transition probability
this is the estimate for PSA
um
right so any questions so far
and once you have this
it's it's just accounting based
algorithm you just count how many
fractions you really arrive at S Prime
among all the sa how many fractions of
those you know really arrive at S Prime
and and that's the the empirical
frequencies is your estimate for the
transition probability
yourself
okay I'm using the right click I should
use the black color okay so and once you
have this uh a tool to estimate the
transition probability then
um you can you can have a model based R
algorithm
I'll still use the right if it's okay I
think the the black one doesn't seem to
be very good
um so the model bits are algorithm
is doing the following so it's pretty
intuitive so first of all you initialize
uh some policy pi maybe randomly let's
say
and then
um you have some
data set initially you have no no data
so there's a d is empty I'm just
defining a notation basically I'm going
to use this data set D some way so and
once you have this uh and then what you
really do is that you say
I'm going to
I have two steps the first step is that
I'm going to estimate
I'm going to
collect some data
so
so collect data
by executing
policy pi
[Music]
um so
so if you actually policy Pi in a real
environment you're going to get some
samples right that's that's our
assumption our assumption is that you
are able to get samples from the Real
Environment you don't know the PSA but
you can get samples from the pic
so so you're actually a policy pie to
get your environment so basically what
you do is you get a family of the
environment of sorry you actually you
actually your policy pie to get some
samples unless the samples you got let's
say they are denoted by S01
um
something and you apply a01
and then you get that's one one so and
so forth and you have X1 and zero two
right this is the same kind of set of
samples here so you get some samples
and and then you add all of this
reaction right
on the two lectures
the trajectories
2D
so D is a kind of like a set of data
and then
I'm using the bar spacing your you know
awkward way
how do I
I think I'll just I have to
so let's say I'm going to
so you got this data
um this kind of data right so
so this is a set of data that is
that is kind of like this okay so and
then uh you add them
okay so on the Second Step this is the
first step you collect some data and
then in the second step
uh your estimate
you estimate the the PSA
using
data indeed
Okay so
uh and let's still use PSE as the
estimator right so suppose you get some
PSA
um
um that is supposed to be estimated for
the real transition Dynamics
um and then in the step C
um so you you can use for example
is value iteration
um all could it could be also part of
situation I guess we didn't have time to
discuss pulse iteration in the last
lecture but if you are interested you
can read lecture notes to see what's the
policy iteration but let's suppose to
use value iteration to get
to get
V Star the value function
um
for the estimated PSA
the estimates you know Dynamics
so just pretend that the isometrics is
the real dynamics and then you solve the
best policy
um the boss the the optimal value
function uh for data Dynamics and then
you take Pi star
uh to be you take Pi on
be the optimal policy
for the same
for the isometrics
foreign
Okay so
so are we done so it sounds like we're
done right because we estimate some it's
kind of everything simple right you
collect some data you ask me the the the
the the Dynamics and then you get the
best policy of
on the isometrics but actually what you
really have to do is you have to take it
you have to have another loop
outer loop that repeat this process so
what you really should need to do is you
take have to take a loop
and
so that after you you have some policy
pie you want to collect some more data
using the current policy Pi initially
the policy Pi was random and you collect
data from the random policy and after
you get some policy Pi then you should
take another loop to collect more data
and then we estimate your transition
Dynamics and then recompute your policy
and then you keep doing this you
probably don't have to do a lot of Loops
but but you have to do sub iterations
so the question is why why you need this
Loop uh Auto Loop right why we can't
just go with the first Dynamics right we
have estimated right so if you ask me
one Dynamics you know if it's accurate
enough then why we cannot go with that
the reason is that there is the in RL
there's this problem with the this kind
of like so-called exploration
exploitation trade-off
um which I'm going to elaborate so so
the immediate problem is the following
so it's possible that in the first round
when you collect data your data is not
very good it's very bad low quality data
right so for example suppose you want to
control a robot and and you initialize
people pause randomly you you just do
some random you just push the random
buttons or control the robot in a random
way then the data you collect are are
basically just some kind of like a on
the nobody just kind of like wiggling
around a little bit right it doesn't
really move much so the data you clock
is actually very very bad and then even
you have a lot of data you see your data
cloud is not good enough just because
the the robot doesn't really do much and
then your ultimate Dynamics is also not
going to be good enough and then
um uh your policy is also good not going
to be good enough so what you really
want is that you want to do this
iterative so the next round when your
policies is kind of like reasonably okay
you collect some higher order higher
quality data and then you do this again
and then your pores becomes even better
and then you get even better higher
quality data so so that's why all you
want to have this Loop another example
you know um is the following so suppose
you have this is another example suppose
for example
um let's say
I guess you probably all some of you
have used this kind of like a automatic
robot to clean the to do the cleaning
for the for the house where you have
this small
um like vacuum that can like a robotic
vacuum that you can that can move in
your house right so if you haven't used
that I think how it works is that it
first kind of like explore your whole
whole room and to try to figure out what
your room looked like and then the next
round is it's gonna kind of like do some
kind of like a
take some introductions to kind of clean
your room you know so that it covers
every part right so so something like
that
um however but if you think about this
right suppose you have said for example
say something like you have a like a a
big room and then you have a small room
adjacent to it right so you have some
robots
um that kind of tries to clean the room
and navigate through the room right so
what if you at the beginning your robot
only kind of goes to this part right so
you just in the first round your policy
just only look at this room then your
Dynamic model will only be able to only
is only accurate for this room right you
only know what's what's happening in
this room what's the chairs what's the
what's the on the stairs or other kind
of like so so far so and so forth right
so
um and but you don't know anything about
this one
so so so the so that's why you cannot
um so that's the that's a typical
situation where the data of the quality
of the data is not good enough because
your your quality of your data doesn't
even cover some part of the room so then
if you don't do anything special then
your robot wouldn't have incentive to go
to this room because the robot doesn't
even know
the existence of this room in some sense
so
um so this is actually even more
challenging the case because here even
you just do this Loop you wouldn't be
able to necessarily wouldn't be able to
kind of like figure out uh this small
room because begin at the beginning you
just you just only see the large room
and you never look at a small room and
then then you figure out of the policy
to clean a large room and you still
don't know the existence of the small
room and you just keep doing this
eventually use the only kind of clean
the large room and you just never notice
the existence of the small room so so in
this kind of cases
um you need even something more than
this kind of algorithm on to on to to be
able to to to work so
um and typically this is called um this
is a phenomenal exploitation
versus exploration
so exportation
basically means that you believe your
current transition Dynamics you just
strongly believe their current
transition Dynamics
um or your current kind of understanding
about the world in the environment right
and you just try to find an optimal
policy for that uh for the current
understanding of about the world and
exploration means that you try to
explore different kind of strategies to
see whether you missed anything in this
world right so in this case you know
maybe you missed the small room so so so
you want to do exploration to figure out
the existence of the small rule and
exploitation really just means that you
just basically do the best thing for the
current map
um so so as you can see you know you
need some exploration to kind of at
least cover the entire kind of like the
entire world so you know like the
existence of any other options so so
typically if you really run this kind of
reinforcement learning algorithm you
have to add some Randomness in the
policy pie so that you can have some
exploration right so you don't want to
just always in every round you just
always collect data from the policy Pi
that is optimal for the for the for the
current environment you also want to
have some extraordinary exploration by
adding some Randomness so so basically
what you really do is that when you
collect data you add some uh by asking
file with some randomness
so in this case you know you have some
small chance to go into the small room
so that you can see the small room and
then you figure out you should actually
kind of clean that small room you know
uh with some kind of like a
trajectory uh with some actions
um so maybe another example is that for
example suppose you can figure out where
where which restaurant you want to go
right in in Palo Alto downtown right so
suppose you just
um suppose so far you know two
restaurants and you know one of them is
better than the other for you
and and the exploitation would mean that
you just always go to the better
restaurant
for your taste right and then you just
keep go to that by the restaurant uh for
you however
um you may also consider some
exploration because you know there are
many other restaurants in Palo Alto and
you don't know the existence of them
even or you don't know whether they are
good on or bad you don't know their
their taste whether their taste fits you
so so exploration means that you should
try some of the other restaurants even
at a risk that those restaurants are not
as good as the one you have known but
you want to try more uh with those uh
try to kind of explore those restaurants
and exploitation means that you just
believe that okay there's no uh nothing
I should explore anymore I just I
believe in the my current evaluation of
all the restaurants I just take the best
one I need to keep going to that best on
that one so um and there's a trade-off
because you know if you keep doing
exploration
then uh you keep trying all different
restaurants then you all inevitably
you're gonna find some restaurants that
are not very good right so and you're
going to suffer and you're gonna say
okay this doesn't work the money you're
gonna you're gonna like have some um bad
energy in some sense
um but um but uh but on the other hand
um if you're only doing exportation you
can miss other opportunities so so it
really depends on and if you really go
into the the RO literature there are
different ways to trade off these two
things right depending on how confident
you are with each of the uh the choices
uh you may you may decide to exploit
more or you want you might decide to
explore more
um okay but I think we are not going to
have enough time to go into the details
there's a huge literature uh here like
even just when you talk about this going
to restaurant thing right which doesn't
have a sequential aspect you just go to
the restaurant and and have lunch or
dinner there's no sequential decision
you still have to think about the
decision the exportation and the
exploration trade-off so is there kind
of like a to do it optimally you have to
be on some kind of careful
[Music]
um
okay any any questions so far
so like like
do we know that we we really we are we
are coming back and it's learning about
the world we are here and how we are
just trying I'm random yeah so so I
guess um maybe you're asking about you
know what uh how do we do expiration
right so what's the kind of the guiding
principle for for doing and it seems to
suggest that one principle could be that
you only want to explore when you can
get collect more information uh yes I
think that's that's that basically uh
it's pretty much like what you said
um but sometimes random actually can
serve that need so if you just do random
perturbation of your current option
typically you get some you get a actual
good amount of information but of course
in some other cases you have to directly
go for those kind of
um in certain places actually actually
you are exactly right so for for the
tabular role case typically what people
do is not just random exploration what
people do is you say you own you take
those actions that are most uncertain
for you so suppose you have some action
that you don't know what outcome would
be you have no idea what the outcome
would be or you have very little idea
you have very huge uncertainty about
what outcome would be you try those
actions more uh as exploration strategy
but for the continuous State space right
so I think it turns out that people most
most of the algorithm works are kind of
like local randomized exploration uh you
don't try some crazy option you try in
your neighborhood I think that's what I
should probably make a lot of sense in
many in in those cases where you have so
many different actions right so
um for example if you if you think about
your career planning like like if you
really have suppose you like in theory
you have really really a lot of actions
actions you can try you can instead of
being at Stanford you can try to be a
professional soccer player right so or
you have you can be a musician you can
be a many different there could be many
things I mean you you are very uncertain
about some of those problems right so
like I wouldn't know what if I try to be
a musician what would happen so
um but but I think we have so many
actions
when you talk about technical videos but
typically we have so many actions I
think you somehow the algorithms most of
the working algorithms tries to explore
locally so so for example I'm a student
here at Stanford and then I try
something
somewhat similar maybe going to intern
at Google or maybe like maybe trying to
try and graduate school or something
like that but I wouldn't try something
completely kind of different
um
um you know there's no we don't have
like a really a strong Theory to to say
exactly what you should do
um so so these are just it's a mixture
of like some theoretical explanation and
some kind of like empirical observations
questions
okay so I got some
um
so I'm going to
use the rest of the the 40 minutes or 30
35 minutes to talk about continuous
State space so I've talked about the
model based Arrow right so now that I'm
going to talk about model based plus
continuous State space
um and the the the the idea is pretty
much
similar uh it's just that you have to
um somehow there is a you have to deal
with the continuous database you'll see
there's some challenge
so
foreign
like at least when I kind of like after
I learned it
um I feel like it has a lot of things to
do with your kind of like life decision
as well like of course you can only 100
trust the algorithm like it's not like
you should Implement an algorithm in
your life decisions
um but but there are some kind of like
inside theory that is useful for
um for the general kind of like this you
know this is a you can model your life
as a reinforcement algorithms it's just
that okay one difference is that
um in a real life you have much more
information
uh like so like in the in the
theoretical formulation you're only
collecting information from the samples
right so you know nothing about the
environment at the beginning any
anything you have to you have to try it
out right like if you want to know
anything about PSA you have to try it
out
um and sometimes you can share more and
sometimes you can travel less but you
still have to try
um in life decisions in many cases you
don't have to try you can already
predict to some extent uh what's the
outcome is
um other than that I feel it's pretty
similar just just my two cents
um anyway so
um I guess so so what you do with
continuous State space
so
um so one easy case just to start with
is when D is two
suppose you have the state space is only
Dimension two I think when this in this
case basically your state space is a
two-dimensional
um pen you have like um maybe like a so
two two axis and one way to do it is
that you just discretize your this state
space into discrete variables right so
before what each of the state is like
two real number but then you say I'm
going to discretize the state space
there's some boundary of course because
your state cannot be too big and then
you discretize something like this
and then for every cell you see all the
states in there is the number of states
in this each of the cell but you say all
the states in that cell is going to be
con treated as one state just because
they're all pretty much similar so as
long as you have like a fine enough
granularity here then you can basically
treat every cell as a single state
so and suppose you have like granularity
up soon then you are going to have one
over absolute Square well of absolute
choices for the first one well absolute
choices for the second one so you have
one of absolute Square choices of states
um and you can probably take absence to
be something like 0.01 I don't know
exactly but you you're gonna get a ref
at a reasonable number of states maybe
maybe quite a lot but not like maybe a
thousands or something like ten
thousands but but it wouldn't be too too
bad
so that's the that's easy easy Choice
um however this doesn't really work for
when your dimension is higher than two I
think when dimensions three it already
becomes tricky because if you think
about you know uh your display is in the
three-dimensional space then
say suppose these three and you do this
round of apps on kind of like uh so each
of these
um size of each of this cell is
absolutely you need one over absolute
so the power three states
I guess it depends on what option you
choose but if you choose absom to be
something at point zero one then you
have like a hundred to the power three
that's like a million which is already a
lot right so so maybe sometimes it's
still okay but generally when these
three is already kind of tricky and then
you can see this doesn't scale very well
because if you have these for any D this
would be one of the absolute power D and
and when D is five basically it's kind
of and impossible completely impossible
so so we need an other approach for but
actually just to just to clarify so when
these two actually this is actually
pretty typically a pretty good idea
because it's simple and clean and when
you don't have to deal with any other
complications the only thing is that you
have one for absolute Square
um States but there's no any other
complications
um it's actually a pretty good solution
I think you know it probably should work
in most of the cases
so but when D is more than three
um it's going to be a problem
so
um so basically what we do is we're
gonna we're gonna redesign everything
that we have discussed you know with
continuous State space in mind
so so I guess there are two questions
one question is how to learn
how to learn
PSA for continuous State space and then
question two is that how do you uh do
the value iteration
of both for continuous database
so
um so for question one
so let's discuss each of them so uh and
the basic idea is that you try to kind
of like extend what you have done to the
continuous State space in some way
um
so regarding question one so how do you
do it
the first question probably is that how
do you even represent
the PSA
right so now you have infinite number of
us here so before for every ice and a
you have a vector to represent right and
the the right so forever I say this PS
is a distribution and it's basically the
vector over I'm possible choices if I
miss number of states but now you have
infinite of s here or maybe exponential
number of ads there and for every PSA
this Vector is actually a very high
dimensional Vector maybe a exponential
dimensional vector or infinimental
vector so how do you even represent this
so
um the idea is that you can change the
way to represent it you don't represent
this uh uh you you you can do the
following there are many ways but this
is one way that is probably common
learning on Dynamics
foreign
so what you do is you first say I'm
going to model
this process as prime example from PSA
by assuming
as Prime is equals to F Asa
plus some noise
this is one option not not all not the
only option but one option is you say
you assume that
ice Prime is computed by applying some
functional ion a and then add some noise
that's my that's my way to sample as
Prime from this two solution so this is
a way to define a distribution the
distribution basically has mean FSA and
some gaussian has some variance you know
um like a cosine like like the same as
the cosine so
so this will give you a random variable
S Prime given as an a
so and this FSA let's say maybe maybe f
as a is deterministic this is just some
function
we want to learn
and this part is the noise
I'll give you the stochasticity
or maybe like a Kasai
is maybe it's from some zero with some
covalent Sigma
so sometimes you just I guess probably
have seen I've seen that this is kind of
almost the same as what we do with
um like uh surprise learning I will just
treat this as a super streaming problem
so S Prime is my label as an a are my
inputs so I'm just trying to predict my
label from the inputs and the way I
model this is I model this by some kind
of like
some function plus noise right and then
you can do Max molecular Hood and the
max molecular hood is just the the
square loss so and you learn that
you learn this model f by some Square
loss
so for example so so you have to
introduce some parametrization for us so
for example F could be
a linear model suppose you say you have
some parameter A and B and your f it
could be just a s plus b
either way
right so this could be the F which is
parametricized by A and B
um so A and B are parameters s and there
are inputs so you just have this linear
model
uh I think this is called linear
dynamical model so this is a linear
model
and another option is that you say I'm
going to say FSA
is equals to
uh maybe you can you can make you can
use the the same idea as the feature uh
like the when you do the kernel you can
say this is like something like a times
V of us
Plus
B times
I don't know I forgot what is this is
called This is called
you just have some other feature
something like this
so both of this
two
fees these are some some features
right so this is um like what we did
with kernel method right so you
introduce some features and then you are
linear in a feature space
of course you can also say that on FSA
um so I guess here department is a and b
as well uh you can also say my FSA if
you have parametric specimens Theta is a
new network
neural network
applied on ice and a
um something like this and this new
network is maybe say
parameter as bad title
so so you just say s and a are
concatenated as inputs of a network and
you apply this network with parameter
Theta and the output will be my FSA
and in each of this case you can model
your S Prime like this
and then you can try to uh
find out the
uh and this becomes a surprise problem
so
what I mean is that
once you have Department transition
right so then you can
say you can
the learning loss function is that
suppose you have some data
suppose
data are
something like I guess I've written this
several times
um S01 a01
is 1 1 so on and so forth
so you have a bunch of trajectories
sorry my massive index
so you have these three actually and
then you you
you break these structures into uh three
tuples
so you mean that you view this
you on the
eyes
a collection of three tuples right so
you say you have I zero one
a01
comma S11
so this is the first three things here
and you view this as the input
and this as the so-called label or
output
and then you say oh I'm going to have
for
these three things which is ice one one
a uh one one and S12
right so this again is the input
and this is a label
and you do this for every
three typos you know in every
introduction so you get the basically
you get a sequence of like three tuples
um
so you guys eventually you guys you know
as
say p minus one and
is the number of triggers
uh 80 minus one and
I guess the
a lot of indexing here but basically
just the view every three concatenate
three consecutive kind of like numbers
as a tuple and you view the first as an
AST the input and the the outcome is the
output
um something like this
okay so you have a data side of this
right so this is a set of size
n times t a is the number of two
actually T is the length of the
trajectory
um and then you do a supervised learning
so you have you just use the surprise
learning
so you do some kind of regression let's
say
you say I'm going to minimize
over my parameter maybe let's call it
Theta
and I minimize this
over
I minimize the laws over all data points
so what is the loss the loss
so there is a i
there's also a t
I is indexing
on the num the trajectories and T's in
the second induction timestamp and every
time you want to predict what you want
to predict as t plus one
in the iot directory
using this function f Theta
as
t i
so this is the input of this Supply
saving problem you apply the model and
then you try to match it with the
um with the output a label of this
problem
and here I'm using a L2 Norm because the
label is a vector right so in many of
the cases you see this parenthesis is
square because in those cases when you
do the typical super string problem your
label is a real number right house price
prediction right so the label is the
house price you know which is a real
number but here the label is a vector
it's the same you just to do the L2 knob
score
sometimes you can change the loss
function you don't have to always use L2
num Square maybe you don't even need
Square sometimes so you can use other
thoughts I want some touch
so
um and once you do this you get the
Theta and this I will say that will be
on model
any questions
so so I think the benefit here is that
before you have to specify
PSA for every ice and a right as a
vector right so now you you learn this
function as Theta so the number of
parameters is Theta and then for every
ice and a you can compute FSA
um if you know the Theta
so that's the that's how you do the
model based RL part uh sorry that's how
you do the model estimation part how you
ask me the Dynamics and then uh you also
need to deal with the value or iteration
how do you do the value iteration for
continuous database space
uh I don't think I have the
the math there so when you do the value
iteration you know before you are trying
to kind of like update the value
function for every state or every time
right so not that's not possible anymore
because you have so many states you
cannot update the value function for
every state actually it's not even clear
how do you even uh how do you even
describe a value function because before
the way you describe a value of function
is you say for every V Star as for every
result I have a number right so but
before you describe it by listing all
the ads right for every us you have a
number that's how you describe V Star
but now you cannot really describe it
like that so what you do is you say I'm
going to parametrize the value function
by again kind of liking before by some
kind of like new network or linear model
right so you can say I parameterize I
write my vrs as
on
um like something like
um maybe one choice is that you can say
this is say that transpose times some
feature of s so this is a feature
and this is the parameter that's my
option
and another option is you say my V of us
is a new network
with parameter Theta applied on a state
s
right so this data is a description of
of the value function
and you need to learn
of course in the other ways to do this
for example one way to do it is that you
can
um for example design some right uh the
right features using physical intuitions
sometimes you know that some coordinates
you know only is only meaningful when it
combines with other currents in some
meaningful way so so I think some Mitch
of this could also work because you
could design some features and then use
these features as input to a new network
um
but generally you just want to have a
parametress form
okay so that so we have done so so after
we have the representation of the value
function and the next question is how do
you do the update right so
before what we did was that
so recall
the update was something like v as is
other to be something like RS
Plus
gamma Max a
all right that's what we did right so we
come we have some working
value for V and we compute the right
hand side of the development equation
and we update the V with the right hand
side and then we repeat
so
um but you cannot do this because you
don't have before we do it for every
eyes
but that's not possible anymore so so
what we do is we try to make this is
true for the eyes we have seen so
basically for continuous State space so
for the continuous case
we just try to uh Ensure
about my equation
for
States
uh that we have seen
you don't you show this for every state
as anymore you just ensure it for the
states you have seen and if you if you
just want to do that then you can do
some kind of loss function to ensure
that
so
um let me elaborate on what what do I
mean here
so
so you first the first step is the
following so your estimate
the right hand side of the Bowman
equation
four
um
first States
say S1 up to s
so I haven't told you exactly how I got
these states right so suppose I got some
states that I have seen right in like in
the algorithm and I want to only ensure
the spell my equation you turn this to
be equal to this or someone encouraged
it they are the same only for this kind
of choice of States s is equal to one of
this
that's my compromise because I cannot do
it for every state
so
um so what I do is that I
I try to First Complete the right hand
side
so how do I get the right hand side for
every state s so what I do is I just
um
so so basically I want to compute
RSI plus this Max thing
but the problem is that you know here I
have a sum over S Prime again that's
again a lot of different choices for us
so what I do is I'm going to first turn
this into
uh
an expectation
we write this as expectation of v as
Prime
and X Prime is sampled from p s i
hey
so after you have the expectation you
can use the empirical sample to estimate
this quantity
so basically what you do is you say
so for every by the way I think I forgot
to mention one thing which is that now
I'm talking about
um I'm talking about uh continuous
uh State space but fine and
action space
just so this is a slightly simpler
question than both of them are continues
um or just because I don't want to
overconfect too much so so the con so
it's continuous State space and final
action space
so
um what I do is I first estimate this
by sampling some X Prime and then I take
the max because you have a final number
of states action space actions you can
just take the max so what you do is you
say
for every a
uh you get
K samples
uh let's call it S1 Prime up to s k
Prime these are sampled from this
transition Dynamics PSA PS uh s i
right so you understand as I you try the
action a and you see what is the outcome
you have a bunch of random outcome
um and then you still Define q a to be
um RSI
plus 1 over k
times this average right you use the
empirical average basically
right the empirical average of PV ice
SJ
Prime so this is supposed to estimate
this is supposed to estimate RS
uh I think I'm missing a gamma here
sorry
it's supposed to ask me RS Plus
RSI
plus gamma
expectation v s i
so I'm supposed to use this to estimate
this without a max
and then I take the max I call
y
I
to be the max of this QA
so then this is supposed to ask me this
one so y i is supposed to estimate this
quantity
and for every eye I have estimate
right so for every eye I have estimated
for the right hand side of this bioma
equation
and then I ensure that this development
equation to be somewhat correct for all
the eyes
um
that I have considered so
step
so step B
I need to enforce
um
like
v as I
to be close to y i right because you
know recall that we have spent so much
effort to complete this y i it's why
it's supposed to be the right side of
the bowel make right hand side of the
biome equation evaluate at is I and I
want this to be close to the left hand
side and how do I do that I do that by
saying I'm Computing Theta
to be
Arc Max
of this loss function that encourages
this and the loss function is simply
just some L2 loss
say
I take the average over all the possible
ice I's and let's say
v
um
my vsi is parametrized by some saying
right work like this way so let's don't
talk about the right works but it works
for anything right so say this is a
neural network
you're not
with Theta applied on x i
minus y i
Square so basically you want this new
network to Output
the right value function that match the
target the target is the right hand side
of the bioma equation actually you know
in the theoretical in the in the RL
papers you do call this target so this
is the target you want to kind of match
and and you want to choose the the
updated such that your left hand side
which is this new network on SI to match
the target
and that's your data that you got in
this step
and again you have to do it's a value
iteration you have to iterate because if
you get stated this way you have to
iterate to recompute your your right
hand side and then after the left hand
side where you call it when you do
development the value iteration you
complete the right hand side and you up
to the right hand side you do this
iteratively so
um So eventually you also have to have
iteration which is
you say
you let's see so you each between these
two steps
so
you say you have a loop
um but I think there's a little bit
to that specify everything yes I think I
specify
okay
so this is the loop
maybe maybe sorry let's
uh
okay yes so
um I'm a little bit I should save some
space before so let's say this is a and
I have a loop here
right so
but this is not still not enough because
this Loop is doing what this Loop is
only doing the value iteration
for
this Iceman after s n
right I haven't told you even how do you
get asthma after I sent right this is
just a bunch of states that you have
seen so and also even you you like you
can update you can do this for every us
or value iteration is not enough because
our model based algorithm has something
even up on the outer layer of the value
iteration right so you're asking the
model and you do value iteration and
then you ask the model again you do
value iteration now you have to do
another outer loop to
update your
uh it's your samples right so because
when you do the model based algorithm
you either have a loop outside the value
iteration so this is the look for Value
iteration and then we have another loop
outside it
um which is supposed to do the uh to
iteratively update the model so
basically you have another look
and in this Loop you collect some data
um say S1 up to SN
you collect this data from
current policy
right you collect the data and then you
do the value iteration on this data and
then on
and then you collect it again and you do
value iteration
so this is how it imitates the model
based our algorithm for Tableau case
right because for the typical case we
also have this Auto Loop where you you
collect data and you do value iteration
and you connected you to evaluate
iteration
so okay so I think I'm missing even more
more step
you collect data
you collect data and also you need to
also in this also Loop you also have to
estimate Dynamics
collect data my bad so collect data
Maybe one and two
you estimate Dynamics
and then three you do the value tuition
and the value iteration consists of
another loop which is this
um
any questions
I see some confusing faces so so
basically I think I erased that oh
actually it was part of party here right
so this was the part that we deal with
the tablet case right so we have to
the the two steps I think maybe I should
actually rename them I just want two and
three
and there was a one step that that was
erased which is the the first stack
which is the clock data
right so before when you do the tabular
case you repeat between the three you
alternate between the three steps
collect data asthma Dynamics validation
and now for the uh for the uh The
Continuous State space
number one is do the same number two was
done by this part of the board where
where we learn this you know with the
supervised learning
and number three is done by
here this part of the board where we do
this A and B stuff the A and B to kind
of like uh to do the value iteration
so so number three is the is this part
where we do the value iteration
and and eventually you have to do a loop
for this one two three on top of this
one two three
okay I guess that's all for today and
for this whole course I guess you know
we have covered you know surprise
learning and surprise learning and
reinforcement learning
um yeah and we try to kind of like cover
more and more deep learning uh these
days but um but also like some of these
maths are included mostly because I
think these are
um kind of the foundations of machine
learning so
um I hope you
um you had some fun with the course
thanks
foreign